today we're going to talk about the 10
warning signs of dementia specifically
Alzheimer's and I have some additional
very important information to share with
you that relates to your genetics for
example if your grandparents or your
parents had it does that mean you're
going to have it I'm also going to touch
on some important information relating
to the actual cause of Alzheimer's
um there's been some recent information
on the amyloid plaque theory that is
completely going to flip things upside
down but before I touch on the warning
signs I just have to say out of all the
stresses that someone experiences
a loss of a loved one a loss of your
mother with Alzheimer's or your father
is probably one of the most devastating
things that can happen not just for you
but for them as well because you're in a
situation where you're gradually losing
yourself and you're losing your ability
to think and remember and locate things
and navigate so it's very very
unstabling it's very confusing and it's
basically terrifying my wife's mother
had Alzheimer's and Karen was so close
to her mom I mean it was her best friend
and it was just tragic to go to the
nursing home and visit her you see all
these family members trying to
communicate and trying to
connect with this person that they love
I mean to this day that Karen just you
know misses her and she thinks about her
um all the time so today I'm going to
talk about the warning signs and I'm
going to give you some things that you
can do to hopefully reverse the
situation in a loved one and even in
yourself okay so with that let's start
with the warning signs first the first
warning sign is a change in language
okay uh coping for different words
trying to look for different words that
you can't remember and just realize as I
go through this it doesn't mean that you
have Alzheimer's or dementia it could be
many other reasons it could be you
haven't slept it could be your blood
sugars it could be a B12 deficiency it
could be many different things but these
are just potential indicators that there
could be a problem in this area when we
talk about a problem with language we
also talk about communication there's
problems with communicating to the
person they're not necessarily paying
attention and then when they talk to you
it could be kind of random and and for
example you might ask them a question
and you know a few minutes later you
might get the answer so there's this lag
time it takes a long time to sink in and
to get a response number two navigation
difficulty finding yourself around uh
town uh around your house things like
that so unfortunately over time that can
get really bad to the point where you
just basically lost all the time number
three sensory so you might have a loss
of taste smell hearing sight and before
constipation what's interesting about
that is my mother-in-law was on a stool
softener right so realize constipation
is part of the gut and there's a gut
brain connection there that sensors a
two-way uh communication Street one area
can affect the other all right number
five personality changes okay they
weren't like they were before their
personality is completely altered when
you have Dementia or Alzheimer's number
six mood changes and this can also occur
because of the frustration that they
know where they're going and it's very
difficult to get certain words out and
remember different things it can be very
frustrating so that's why it's really
important not to correct someone if they
make a mistake with words or anything
because that not only frustrates them
but it can actually make it worse if
you're constantly correcting someone
even if they don't have Alzheimer's or
dementia you basically kind of lock it
in where they start to do it more and
more and more all right number seven
memories locating pictures and thoughts
that you had before are difficult
especially recent memories okay that
could be one of the indicators number
eight thinking the ability to solve
problems now solving problems also
involve having a memory of past similar
situations that you're drawing on and if
you can't access that data it's very
difficult to solve problems
so if someone can't solve problems
they're going to have a lot more
problems built up and that's going to be
more frustrating all right number nine
their overall awareness is affected so
you can kind of even look in their eyes
and see that they're not a hundred
percent there they're that means their
attention is not on the environment in
the present it's somewhere else and
number 10 they keep repeating themselves
so they might have no idea that they
just said something twice
so again if they do that don't remind
them because that'll make it worse just
move on and just ignore it now there's
some recent information I want to share
with you and I'm going to put the link
down below of a video that I did on this
topic and basically there was a
researcher in 2006 that committed fraud
on this area of Alzheimer's and
fabricated data that wasn't true and
this related to amyloid plaquin causing
Alzheimer's because the problem is that
even people without Alzheimer's has this
plaquing and they don't have Alzheimer's
and so all the research money that is
went to this Theory okay and this has
not been fruitful I mean I'm talking
like
millions and millions of dollars and so
now that cast a huge doubt on the actual
cause of Alzheimer's so there's some new
theories about Alzheimer's that makes a
lot of sense and I did a whole video on
it and that relates to the lysosome and
what's a lysosome lysosome is a it's a
little part of the cell that like the
garbage disposal okay and so that part
of the cell becomes dysfunctional in
Alzheimer's patients where the uh cell
cannot uh get rid of the garbage so the
garbage keeps backing up you can imagine
in your house if you never took out the
garbage okay what would happen over a
period of time it's going to get really
toxic and that's exactly what happens
with the neurons and there's a lot more
data I want to share with you on this
lysosome uh this angle of the cause of
Alzheimer's because right now if you
look at all the factors that align with
that it all makes total sense what
happens in the lysosome is a condition
called autophagy and autophagy is the
recycling of you know garbage
to get fuel in the body and also to get
new cells and so I'm going to get into a
little plan to give you to show you how
to improve autophagy but the current
theory that makes the most sense with
the cause of Alzheimer's is a
dysfunctional autophagy or lysosome
situation you know there's mixed data
about this that there's certain specific
genes that will cause Alzheimer's but
since Alzheimer's is multifaceted
there's a lot of different aspects to it
and multiple causes there could be
multiple genes that you can have
mutations with that can cause this
problem let me explain like for example
mini strokes that can create a type of
Alzheimer's called vascular Alzheimer's
there's other causes where you have
brain injury from some other cause and
then there's another angle where you can
have a problem with um methylation and
without trying to get too complex
basically if you have a problem with
methylation you're going to build up a
lot of heavy metals in the brain and
that could be aluminum or even lead or
even iron and that can create
Alzheimer's so with all these different
causes you have related genes that are
involved with those causes and so
recently A lot of people are getting
their DNA tested and knowing your DNA as
far as what mutations you have it
doesn't necessarily tell you you're
going to have that problem it just tells
you have weaknesses within the genes so
I think it's important to get that test
but also know if one of your
grandparents had this problem or your
parents had it potentially you could
have a weakness within your genetics
which doesn't mean you're going to get
it it just means that that Gene could
turn on at a certain point in your life
and then you could get it but there are
so many things you can do to bulletproof
yourself to make sure that Gene stays
off and that's what I'm going to talk
about so there are a number of genes
that I've researched on this topic I'm
not going to kind of give you all the
complexity but I'll just talk about one
of the genes it's called apoe and that
Gene has to do with turning on late
stage Alzheimer's so something you would
get after age 65 but there's different
forms of that Gene okay so you have the
E2 version which helps protect against
Alzheimer's and then you have the E4
version which is different if you have a
problem with that Gene it will increase
your risk of getting Alzheimer's by 15
to 25 percent okay and then you have
another version of this APO e Gene which
is the E3 version which will not have
any effect on Alzheimer's so basically
if you get your DNA tested and you have
a problem with that Gene um specifically
like E2 or E4 then it just tells you you
need to be doing things to bulletproof
yourself right now now there's another
Gene called app that has a lot to do
with what I said before on autophagy
which is that lysosome cleaning up all
the garbage in the cell if you have a
problem with that then you need to be
doing a lot more autophagy and
strengthening the cleaning out process
because you have a problem with
detoxification if you don't do extra
things the cells become very very toxic
and then there's other genes involving
the methylation and I've touched on that
a little bit but if you have a problem
with that Gene what you need to do to
solve it is to take larger amounts of
B12 not the synthetic version but the
natural version as well as the natural
version of folic so what happens if you
don't have this good methylation problem
you're going to build up heavy metals
okay you're gonna have a hard time
detoxifying Mercury so this tells us you
shouldn't be eating certain types of
fish okay this tells us that you should
be very careful about taking too much
iron especially iron in synthetic
supplements especially iron in enriched
flour products so understanding the
weaknesses that you have can give you a
lot of
um Power in doing something about it
because now you're aware where your weak
links are now another heavy metal would
be aluminum right and of course the
aluminum deodorants and aluminum pans
should be avoided so now the question is
okay and I summarize this for you to
make it really simple
um let's say you have problems with all
all of these genes okay that relate to
Dementia or Alzheimer's what can you do
and this would be good for any person
with Alzheimer's they're very important
and actions you can take that are
epigenetic actions which are lifestyle
actions that can help you control your
genes just because a gene is mutated
doesn't mean you're gonna have a problem
with it okay so these genetic factors
will keep things in check okay number
one is to change the fuel that they're
running on to the ketones okay you want
to run the brain on ketones the brain
loves ketones it's a preferred Fuel and
I'm talking about going from glucose to
ketones and the way you do that is
putting the person on a low carb diet as
well as doing intermittent fasting okay
both of those will induce ketones and it
will support the brain even if there's
damage to the brain because the first
thing to go downhill with Alzheimer's is
damage to the hippocampus the nipple
campus is all about navigation memory
and things like that so a ketone fuel
will bypass the damage feed the neurons
directly because because at the heart of
the matter is a shrinking brain a brain
that's addressing a brain that has
neurons that don't connect well anymore
and so they're starving of fuel so if we
feed them ketones we will instantly see
at least some good Improvement all right
number two you want to induce autophagy
autophagy is not some cellular thing
it's a condition that you put your cells
into so they can recycle garbage okay
and damaged proteins and the most potent
way to stimulate autophagy is with
fasting okay regular intermittent
fasting with periodic prolonged fasting
but you can also induce autophagy with
exercise so you don't even have to go to
a gym exercise you can be exercising at
your home doing a mild version of it you
know stretching things like that but any
exercise is better than no exercise the
next thing is green tea these
phytonutrient treat it in green tea e g
c g can greatly help you and also induce
autophagy curcumin is another really
good natural phytonutrient in turmeric
that can help induce autophagy number
three
omega-3 fatty acids specifically the EPA
and the DHA which your brain desperately
needs and I would recommend getting it
from cod liver oil make sure if you're
getting your omega-3 from fish that you
do the least amount of heavy metals or
Mercury is possible because what we're
trying to do is we're trying to
eliminate all these extra things that
can create problems and that would be
number four reduce heavy metals okay so
you're going to have to understand what
fish that you can eat and one fish you
can't selenium is the trace mineral that
helps reduce Mercury so if you do have
fish maybe you take selenium at the same
time to lock up that mercury so it
doesn't become a problem distilled water
is something I would also recommend
unfortunately this might be a pain but
to get one of those distillers where you
have stainless steel okay and not the
plastic jug but glass and you can make
your own distilled water and consume a
good amount of the water being distilled
water why because you have to realize
what is in tap water I mean even like
even builted water there's still all
sorts of chemicals when you distill it
you remove everything and so it's a
really good way of drinking pure water
without the heavy metals as well as
pulling out metals from your body okay
it's a great detox and then you can just
put the minerals that you want back in
so that's really important
make sure you don't take uh supplements
that are synthetic because a lot of
times it has the wrong type of iron and
that can really mess with all sorts of
things because we don't want these
synthetic vitamins and we don't want
these Elemental minerals from
supplements so it has to be really like
food based or plant-based type nutrition
not food I'm talking about the
supplements themselves make sure that
they're really like food based number
five methylation I mentioned on that B12
okay you need a lot more B12 you can get
a supplement with B12 and folate if you
have this problem and so there's a real
simple genetic test to see if you have a
problem with methylation okay but then
the solution is simple B12 and folate
number six medications okay if your
loved one is on medications you need to
work with the doctor to get them off
because even with my mother-in-law we
found that she was on incontinence
medication and she was on all these
things that had side effects of memory
loss so once we made those changes she
did a lot better okay I didn't resolve
the problem but it improved the problem
then we have number seven vitamins now
these specific vitamins have a direct
effect over your genes okay so we have
vitamin A I'm not talking about
beta-carotene the precursor I'm talking
about actual retinol from things like
liver and egg yolk cheese things like
that then we have vitamin D which will
improve things like inflammation in your
brain and then there's B1 okay don't get
the synthetic version make sure it's
from natural sources like nutritional
yeast B1 is probably the most important
vitamin for the hippocampus which is the
first area of the brain to shrink when
you have dementia vitamin C if you take
an Alzheimer's patient they're nearly
always deficient in vitamin C so vitamin
C is really important too I would not
get this synthetic version I would get a
food base or just eat foods high in
vitamin C the top vitamin C Food believe
it or not is sauerkraut vitamin E very
powerful antioxidant not just good for
the heart very good for your brain
especially the structures of the brain
that relay uh you know memories things
like that and then we have vitamin K1
and this is interesting because people
were on like kumichin drugs which
basically block vitamin K1
have a higher risk of getting
alzheimer's than people that don't and
you get a lot about vitamin K1 from dark
leafy green vegetables and then number
eight lion's mane which is a mushroom
and it even has regenerative properties
for brain tissue as well as neural
protective properties as well but a lot
of people have dementia report amazing
changes when they take lion mane now if
you haven't seen this video in
Alzheimer's that I actually talk about
the amyloid plaque not being the cause
for it you should definitely check that
one out next very important I put it
right here